Jorden you just got an extended look at
outer worlds a game that I think many
people are interested in because it
basically seems like fall out in space
yeah that's pretty much exactly what it
is I mean this is the original creators
behind the original fallout just
releasing a single-player game that
takes fallouts formula Fallout New Vegas
as formulas specifically and just puts
it into a space setting yeah I mean
first thing I'm curious about is I mean
one of the huge issues that a lot of
people bring up with Bethesda in fall
games is that the gameplay isn't great
yeah
granted you didn't get to play it but
you did get to see it in action how did
it look like does it look like it would
feel better I know that's hard to answer
yeah it looked better than what Peter
saw months ago where there was just one
person shooting with just one gun kind
of freeze framing at certain points to
get a better shot what I got to see was
a person who had multiple weapon so like
a shrink-ray a shotgun or what shrink
ray a shrink ray that's like pretty cool
you actually shoot the person and they
shrink down in size and they just become
significantly weaker and you get to find
out that the reason your character is
able to slow down time is it's a side
effect of being frozen for 70 years as
you were going into space and you
essentially have brain damage and that
translates into a superpower and while
you're frozen and looking over someone
it's very similar to how involve out
where you can see whether or not where
you're going to shoot someone it's going
to [ __ ] them or blind them they've
showed us how if you shoot someone in
the crotch area it causes them to just
double over in pain and then it makes it
okay like easy to take them down so
you're gonna kind of see how someone's
going to react depending where you shoot
them and with what gun you can shoot
them with before combat even starts
we're just very fall out another big
fallout thing and something that they're
making a big point of is that the story
changes depending on your choices yes so
you kind of saw some of that in the demo
correct yeah we specifically got to see
a mission where we were going to a
planet that was a student that was
essentially run by this woman who wanted
her competitor killed and when you spoke
to her she said you can either kill him
or you can do something to like stop
production
his factory which would ruin him and
then when you actually got to the
factory both of those options were
presented to you but you also has the
option of when you went up to the dude
he offered to essentially just give you
bacon tumors for life which is in this
game
pigs are harvested for their tumors that
tastes like bacon interesting yeah it
was it's it's it's a game it's a story
of and so you had then the choice of
either going back and killing the person
who originally gave you the job
destroying the factory killing the dude
or just walking away and not doing
anything and they wouldn't actually show
us what the outcome of any of those
choices were they're like you're going
to have to wait for the actual game
because they wanted to really focus in
on how your choices really impact the
story that you're going to have and so
they didn't want to spoil what any of
the choice outcomes were so we GameSpot
would go into it blind so one of the
things that they've talked about is
companions did you have a companion with
you did you or did they have a companion
with them were they able to interact
with the companion yes any of that so we
had two companions one was Ellie who is
the girl that's seen in some of the
outer worlds trailers that we've had so
far she's the one with the shorter hair
so this actually kind of reminded me
almost a little bit of Mass Effect in a
way because they'll interject in
conversations offering their own
opinions
depending on how you respond to people
in kind that kind of changes your
standing with okay the people so they
might decide to leave you if you annoy
them too much or you do something gets
their morals you kill their friend or
they might support you a lot more and
befriend you depending on that and that
unlocks specific perks in combat so for
example one of the people that we had
their perk was leader so our character
actually wasn't the leader of the squad
they had given leader to one of the
spontaneity right and so who did that
character kind of just call the shots
and the player would follow it was kind
of this weird thing where you as the
player would instigate combat so you
would take the first shot but at that
point
at that moment the person who was leader
would like take a large yeah and like
kind of like charge and and with guns
blazing and like point out like which
enemies like attack first and stuff like
that and they didn't directly state that
it was a way to kind of make the game so
possibly easier for someone who's not
used to this kind of game but I have a
feeling that's kind of what it's for if
you don't quite know what you should be
doing on the battlefield you can then
assign that role to another person to
charge ahead and do the commanding
action for you and they'll boost other
people with certain perks depending on
what type of leader they are so you're
talking about perks
now flaws are also a big part of this
scheme right did you see any of those in
action because those sounds kind of cool
they sound like they could kind of they
they improve on that role-playing aspect
so unfortunately I could I only saw a
fear-based flaws so basically like if
your person dies to an enemy too many
times then they're afraid of that enemy
so you could develop I think they just
called it robot phobia or if you died a
robots too many times and every time you
see a robot enemy you take a just a bad
like status effect and that just changes
depending on how you've been dying to
the robots repeatedly you can also get
ones like scared of the dark so like in
the mission I described earlier there
was an option instead of fighting your
way through the factory to get to the
boss you could sneak through the sewer
system but it's dark in there
so if you were afraid of the dark that
wouldn't necessarily be a viable option
for you but I did speak to the narrative
director and she explained that there
are some flaws that are not entirely
fear-based like the character she
created she wanted to make a stupid
character because that's now the type of
character bill that you can have and
there's like stupid dialogue options
let's get warrior I want to character
but she forgot to do that in the
character creator but she fell off a
cliff so many times that her character
developed a severe concussion and brain
damage and so they got certain perks
that made them into a stupid character
that's kind of how flaws kind of work
they are negative in some way but you do
get a perk out of them and they lost the
entire game so you can
just have like a stack of flaws on your
character but whenever a flaw pops up
you get the choice of whether or not you
decide to take it so kind of going back
to the robot example you die to a robot
a bunch of times you developed a fear of
it it would be like you're now scared of
robots do you want to be scared of
robots if you decide to be scared of
robots you'll do less weapon damage
against them but you'll get buff
whenever you see them which will allow
you to run extra fast okay um and see
then you get to decide at that moment
whether or not you want to go with that
or decide to be like I don't really want
that trade-off and you can just erase it
but if you do decide to pick it you are
stuck with it the rest of the
playthrough they'd be like sorry you
can't go to therapy or anything like
that get over your fears or whatever
maybe therapy of the dlc so last thing
it sounded like they didn't give you a
good idea of the scope of the game but
they have said not to expect like a
giant open world but you will be
planet-hopping
what was the setting like what kind of
what was the planet like that you're on
because some of those planets look
really vibrant and interesting and have
alien life and all sorts of weird cool
things yeah so we were specifically on a
planet called monarch and no you didn't
do any planet hopping like you know go
back to your ship in is he okay
unfortunately they did explain that most
of the planets that you've been to have
been terraformed to be like earth so you
won't experience a like different
gravity or severe like weather changes
or stuff like that most of them are just
aesthetically different it seems but the
area we explored was fairly
self-contained it was about the size of
what some of the planets were in Mass
Effect Andromeda
we're like there is a space to explore
but it's not like witcher assassin's
creed audience size and scope
well that was outer worlds for more news
and previews from e3 2019 make sure to
stay-tuned the game spot
[Music]
you